this entire talk has
seriously been inspired by a
conversation between two professional
adults
where one person said we came up with
some rules that automated bottleneck
and on the other side of the room there
was someone saying but that's not ai
it's not even data science and kind of
what i want to talk about is that
back in the good old days we had these
systems that would do data science
but the way they worked is fundamentally
different than what we do nowadays
before it was kind of normal that you
said well we've got some data
and we want to automate this decision
making process so what we then do is we
get a domain expert in
and maybe with some probability rules
but effectively we get the domain
expert to come up with some rules such
that we can
automate this decision making labeling
like we can generate labels this way we
can automate decisions
that's how that used to work nowadays
it's a lot more fashionable to not
you know do the effort of actually
understanding the data and sort of
coming up with domain rules
instead nowadays what we do is we just
apply a lot of math
and geometric tricks to separate data
points
with this thing called machine learning
we just put it in a big bowl
and eventually rules will come out now
there's merit to this idea because it's
automatable and you know
we also tend to get high accuracy scores
but i've started wondering for a while
now
that in this transition from these
rule-based systems down to this more
machine learning way of thinking
that maybe we should admit that we
didn't get better at solving all of the
problems out there
in fact maybe this machine learning way
of thinking is introducing new kinds of
problems
and maybe what we should do is figure
out a better way to combine the two
that we can say well we've got these
rule-based systems that the machine
learning can use
and we've got this machine learning that
the rule-based systems can use
my hypothesis is is that if we approach
problems this way
odds are that we have better solutions
so the way i want to
talk about this is first i want to talk
about some lessons i've learned while
making content for the spacey project on
youtube
then i would like to also discuss some
lessons i've learned in the past half
here
while working for my new employer raza
and then i want to maybe
take those lessons and see if we can
apply them to psychic learn
which will then conclude by by saying
well i've made this new package and i
think it's going to help solve some
problems
especially in this particular space
so let's talk about a very specific
problem that you see quite commonly in
natural language processing
there's this problem called ner which
stands for named entity recognition and
what it basically boils down to is that
when presented with a bit of text
you might want to be able to detect
specific entities from it
you can think of like phone numbers for
example but you can also think of well
i have these people references that i
would like to retrieve
maybe there's a reference to an
organization or to a city or to money
um but we would like to have an
algorithm that can detect very specific
entities for us
in an automated way and what i've been
doing in the last year kind of as a
hobby project
the creators of spacey reached out to me
and asked me if i was willing to help
them
make some good content on youtube and
i've been solving a variant of this
problem
i wasn't interested in detecting people
though what i thought was interesting
is to go out there and get me a data set
about
programming languages because i figured
it would be interesting to see if i can
make an algorithm
that can automatically detect
programming languages or programming
tools from a text
because i think there's some interesting
applications that you can do with that
if you can do that properly
the thing though is it's actually quite
a hard problem
it's by no means obvious i mean sure
it's pretty easy to detect like
the string of python i suppose right i
mean that's relatively easy
just reg exit and you're done but the
problem is you can't always do that
because you got this programming
language called go
and the thing with go is it is a really
common
like word in the english language but
the way it's most often used is not in
reference to a programming language
in fact go is the most common verb in
the english language
so even if you were to throw embeddings
at it odds are you're not going to be
hitting the thing you're interested in
so you got something maybe more clever
and machine learning algorithms actually
have a hard time doing this so i had to
do something else pragmatic
so what i'll do now is i'll just show
you the short version of the trick that
got me there but then i'll talk about
the larger issue when i'm done talking
about syntax
but what i kind of want to do just real
quick is just show you how this amazing
feature in spacey works and how it's
helped me solve this problem
here's the jupiter notebook and what i'm
doing here is i'm loading up a natural
language processing model from spacey
the small english model that's trained
on the web corpus to be specific
in short what spacey does is you can
take that model object
give it a bit of text and what comes out
is a document that contains tokens
and in this particular case for the
english language it's just a white space
pardon tokenizer but one of the things
that spacey will do
for me is it will add information to all
of these separate tokens there's a
machine learning model that's quite
general that does that
in particular what you're going to get
is this token
what's the part of speech for it so you
can imagine well is it a noun or is it a
verb
a verique word by vuklik namwort in
dutch um
and the thing is that's kind of nice is
given such a general model for the
grammar
it's relatively easy to come up with a
rule-based system for the go programming
language
and in spacey what you would do is you
would say well
i've got this matcher object
and the matcher basically accepts a
pattern definition
which in this case would be well if the
text is lowercase go
and the part of speech of that token is
not a verb
okay then i can match and say that that
is indeed the go
programming language what i can also do
is i can add a second pattern saying if
it's golang
as text and it's probably also about the
go programming language
and suddenly when you just come up with
this fairly simple rule based system
it just kind of works here we see that
i program and go go is detected
correctly
i go and write code well go is a verb
here so it's not detecting that as a
programming language
how to make web requests and go it kind
of works
now of course i'm using something
machine learning under the hood to make
this rule based system
but i hope that you would agree that
this is relatively robust and
i can stand by my own domain knowledge
that this will probably work for a lot
of cases
and just to give like a slightly better
impression of what else you can do with
these rules
what you can also do is you can generate
these rules automatically
because in the end the definition is
just a list with a python dictionary
inside of it
what you can also do is write a function
such that you can also capture the
version of a programming language
if you're doing natural language
processing and you're interested in
fetching programming languages
i hope that you would agree that python
2.7 is different than python 3.6
it'll be kind of a bummer if we fetched
python but not the version number
but the nice thing about this rule based
system is that i don't have to do this
endless labeling or
collecting tons of data i can just kind
of come up with a rule
and that'll probably go ahead and work
so i hope if nothing else that you would
agree that this rule-based system
it's not even really machine learning
end-to-end anything but it is really
pragmatic it is super helpful
this however was only the introduction
the real lesson comes now
because you have to imagine i now have
this matcher object
and the match object is just quite
pragmatic i can just
come up with some domain knowledge apply
that to some csv
files i can look at some rows and i can
look at the csv file for a bit maybe add
some more matcher rules
um but by doing this what i got
effectively was this data set that i
could go ahead to label
what i then did is i took that label
data set and then i went ahead to train
this
actual machine learning model spacey
comes with some deep learning models for
you to use as well
so what i did effectively was first make
this matcher ruler
and then get this data set such that i
can make a machine learning model
and then i can kind of compare both
approaches i also hope just here you
would agree that's useful
because we would expect this machine
learning model to perform much better
than
the basic rules so to say if the basic
rules work better we should not consider
this guy
so spacing makes this quite easy from
the command line you can
basically save your rule based system as
well as your machine learning model and
you can do some comparisons
and one thing that stuck out to me was
that you know if you look at the f1
score
this is the machine learning model this
is the the other one the rule-based one
and you know this is just way higher and
the reason why it's way higher
is because the precision is way better
on the machine learning side
now a bit bit of a hint at these moments
you shouldn't go ahead and say ah
the machine learning model is there for
better because there's something really
weird happening here and i'm wondering
if you can see it
in the interest of time i'll just tell
you but
isn't it kind of weird that the recall
for the machine learning model
is lower than the recall for the
rule-based system
i might argue that the rule-based system
that's bounded right um
the machine learning model can sort of
hopefully look outside of the bounds
that i as a human have declared
and maybe generalize by covering more
ground but that's not at all what's
happening here
apparently the precision is higher not
the recall
so then i'm wondering is this machine
learning model even generalizing
so at moments like this i like to not go
for the better model at moments like
this i like to understand what the
difference is
so the way i went about that is by
basically saying well let's not take the
qualitative route let's maybe do this a
bit more
uh qualitative so let's not go for
quantity let's go for quality that one
sorry
and here's some examples that i found in
instances where they both
failed effectively a lot of that was
contributable to the tokenizer
when you have something like c sharp and
you have c sharp version seven
or c sharp immediately a comma and then
like a list of programming languages
okay it's good to understand that the
tokenizer that's trained on normal
english languages
is gonna have a bit of trouble here um
it's still it's not gonna help me but it
is good to understand a failure scenario
for the system
instances where both models tended to
work equally we're moments where we're
talking about java and python and golang
and
and javascript those were interested it
just got all of them
but there were moments where there was
disagreement between both models and
that's where the interesting thing
started happening
in particular the main thing i was
surprised by was that the machine
learning model wasn't unable to capture
common lisp
this surprised me because common lisp is
pretty well defined you can just get it
by string matching
but then after investigating i found out
that common lisp doesn't exist
in the training data at all the reason
why common list was detected by the rule
based system
was because i was able to write down
with my domain knowledge that this
programming language actually exists
and this is a nice reminder a rule-based
system can actually make
a proper classification even if there's
no data
that's the art of it that's what a
rule-based system can do
if there's no examples of something that
you're interested if there's no examples
of the thing that you're interested in
machine learning is not going to help
you but it's weird because you sometimes
are able to define what you're
interested in even if you don't have
data for it
so this was a clear win for the rule
based system but there was something
else happening as well
the fact that it couldn't detect go
indicated a more subtle problem
and here's the issue java
python and javascript those are all
pretty easy languages to detect
but they're also by far the most
frequent languages out there
if i'm not mistaken i think java python
and javascript are the most popular ones
out there
so it's no surprise that the stack
overflow data set therefore has lots of
examples of those
and maybe not as many for go
and if i then start thinking about oh
yeah but the precision was way higher
and the recall was lower
then you can start wondering well that
data set that i'm judging this system on
if it only has these easy examples
then i'm judging my grid search maybe on
the wrong thing and there's evidence of
that happening now
so i'm super happy i didn't do grid
search here
but then now you get to think about how
to actually solve this problem
and i i really like the system that we
ended up with
back to the drawing board what i ended
up doing is i said well let's have a
minimum
oops let's have a minimum amount of
examples
uh per programming language so you know
just to make sure that
also the more obscure languages we have
at least 50 examples of each
in the training data just start with and
it includes some of the languages that
are harder to detect
next what i did is i said well let's
just have a look
at when both of these models disagree
now let's also say that the instances
where both of those disagree
that's the moment when i'm going to
start labeling again i'm not just going
to grab
randomly from the csv file because odds
are i'm just going to get the popular
languages
and i want to have a general model but
the cool thing is if i
work via this flow every time i do an
iteration
harder instances get into this labeled
data set the machine learning model will
get better
but also the matcher because i'm
labeling manually
i can also get inspired to add a new
rule to the matcher
so every time i'm doing this the matcher
gets better the machine learning model
gets better
which also means that these moments
where i disagree
become more interesting and i think
this is a really nice way to think about
solving a problem it's
also about understanding your problem a
bit better and
to be honest you could not have gotten
here without
this rule-based system it actually
helped me design all of this
and in the aftermath one thing i was
happy with
is yes the scores after became a lot
worse than what i had before
but i didn't care because the data set
that i'm applying this on
is one that's more reliable in
particular the main thing that i really
loved seeing
was the fact that the recall actually
increased
so the precision stayed the same between
both models but now at least i had
evidence that the machine learning model
was generalizing beyond the rules that i
had
another thing that i really like is i
have a rule based system as well as a
machine learning one
they both work on fundamentally
different ways so
whenever they agree i have a really
strong signal that is probably a
programming language
so just a few observations we've seen
that a rule based system definitely can
save
ml in situations where you don't have a
lot of data
the rule-based system made the
statistical system better the
statistical system also made the
rule-based system better
the interaction wasn't just between
systems i the human in the loop also
understood the failure scenarios of both
model a lot better by doing this
and my labeling strategy is really
effective now but moreover
by thinking about rules this way and
checking if they work i have a
fundamentally different way of
approaching a machine learning problem
i'm actually iterating on my data here
as well and not just my
model and that is a fresh perspective if
i compare to what most people do when
they call fit predict
so i hope that this demonstrates some of
the utility of these rule-based systems
but it's not just with spacey that i've
noticed that this is super useful
um i nowadays work for a conversational
company and what we do is
we try to make a system that makes it
easy for you to
generate a very proper and very safe
conversational agent uh chatbots and
that sort of stuff
and one thing that can happen when
you're you know making such a system
is that you can have a conversation in
which
the user asks the virtual assistant are
you a human
and what we would like the virtual
assistant to do primarily
is to reply by saying nope i'm uh i'm
not a human
we really don't want to have the ethical
concern that our systems are going to
pretend to be humans
and after that we really like them to
recover the conversation that they were
doing already
so at rasa when i just started we had
recently made the system
that was really good at recovering so
it's actually quite hard to fool i've
tried it a bunch of times but we now
have a system that can take this
training data
and it's really really good at saying
well okay this is an interruption
we now have to get back to the topic at
hand
but if you think about what's more
important what's more important is this
part that
no matter what happens in my
conversation i'm always able to say
i'm not a human that's the ethical thing
that's the part that we actually care
more of
and that's also where maybe there's a
small concern if you think about like
an example of this like the training
data you would have for such a system
one risk that you might have is that all
of these are your human questions
that they're asked at the beginning of
your conversation as opposed at the end
it can be that we have too many examples
in our training data
where we have easy examples so to say
but that in production if someone were
to say at the end of a conversation
are you a human that we might not give
this response which is like
super important so then you can wonder
do we really want to have this decision
being determined by a machine learning
model
or do we maybe just want to add a rule
as an insurance policy
if we detect someone is asking this
question no matter what else is
happening in the conversation
we must always reply that we're not
human
and if you think about it that's also a
rule-based system
and that idea of being able to add this
insurance policy
that's actually a new feature that we've
added in rasa 2.0 it's something that is
going to come out in a couple of weeks
another way of fixing this issue
is not to say well you have to introduce
a rule certainly what you can also do
is you can iterate on data but one thing
that's likely not going to help you
is iterating on the model it's going to
be
kind of dangerous if you really strictly
care about this insurance policy
to trust that the grid search will solve
all of this
and that's kind of what we saw before as
well we kind of want to have systems
that play by the rules we don't just
want to have
optimal grid search we want to have
models that have other types of
properties that we're interested in
and at the moment we might be
overfitting on
grid searches so i've talked about the
text use case now
rules can save the day in data poor
situations even without data rules are
awesome domain knowledge is great
we have safety mechanisms and we can
apply these rules to subsets of data
that are really well understood
but the main question that you might
have now for yourself
is can we do this on non-text data like
all these results are great but so far
i've only argued for them in the text
domain
and we can ask ourselves well can we
maybe do this for tabular data
as well
and i would say yeah i think we can
let's say that you're world of warcraft
and you have
session logs of every player that's ever
played your video game
and you want to figure out who's going
to churn and who's going to keep on
playing
sure you can make a machine learning
model i think that's a good idea
but before you apply the machine
learning model there's probably also a
rule you can just apply
if you're the kind of person that plays
world of warcraft at midnight during new
year's eve
then you know you're probably a hardcore
gamer you're definitely well invested in
this
do we really need a machine learning
model to tell us that you're probably
not going to churn
or can we maybe design a system where we
say well you know what
we have some sort of a rule that just
says you're a heavy user or you're not
and if you're a heavy user then don't
even bother with a machine learning
algorithm we kind of already know what's
going to happen
only when we have to resort to a machine
learning model that's where we're going
to fall back to it
and there's actually lots of systems
that can be written this way let's say
you're doing fraud
i don't know if you're a tax agency if
you're a child and you have above
median income okay that's a risk if
you're a person with more than 10 bank
accounts
i don't need a machine learning model
just you're a risk that that's already a
business rule i can go ahead and apply
only after you've done lots of these
rules maybe then you can say okay and
this is something i'm going to
give to the machine learning model as a
final resort so to say
and you can even think of like proper
safety constraints on the system
if you get a new data point x and that
data point x is considered an outlier
as in the machine learning model has
never seen anything like it
then it shouldn't have an opinion on it
maybe if we detect an outlier we can
also say ah
business rule you gotta fall back now
and if the certainty isn't high enough
for your machine learning model
okay another good reason to not automate
the prediction
again we're dealing here with a
rule-based system and i hope that you
would agree that you don't have to be in
a text domain
to take these rules kind of serious
there's actually something cool you can
do
if you can join your machine learning
approach with these rules
then the question is though like i hope
i've convinced you that at least
in your mind you can agree that there
has to be some interaction here
there's benefits to be had it's not just
benchmarking this system against machine
learning
interaction here will be cool so now
the only question you might have is well
what can we do to make this as easy as
possible
to sort of use your human knowledge and
rules in scikit-learn
and for that i am announcing now that i
have made this new package called
human learn and as a name might imply
you can kind of guess what it does
what i'm going to do now is just give
you a simple overview of like two of the
main features
it's my mom texting me um
so here we go i'm in a notebook
and let's say i've got this data set
called load titanic i have to predict
whether or not you survived the titanic
disaster and i'm able to do that based
on
all of this information
if i can come up with a simple rule then
one thing i can imagine is if you paid
more for a ticket you're probably closer
to a lifeboat
i can definitely imagine that if you
were a first class paid a lot
that you're more in the upper deck and
probably on the lower deck
so just as a benchmark how about i just
say look just take this column the fare
and if you're and let's just pick a
threshold and if you're over the
threshold then you probably survived and
if you're under the threshold you
probably didn't
it's a simple machine learning model but
if only as a benchmark i hope you would
agree
it's not the worst idea
and what's the easiest way to write such
a rule based system in python well
probably a function what you're probably
going to do is you're going to have a
function
that takes a data frame as input maybe
it has a threshold over here
and what you want to do then is you want
to maybe say something like hey
if we're over a certain threshold
predict one otherwise predict zero
and do that for all the rows the only
issue is
that this function is not a scikit-learn
compatible classifier
so the first thing that this library
does is it just makes it easy to turn
these functions
into scikit-learn compatible classifiers
if you define it this way
you have your argument here that you
also define here then
what this class will do is it will make
sure that you have a function that you
can grid search over
which in turn means you can use it for
benchmarking
in particular what you're going to see
here below is the code that is needed to
do that
but the more important and i think more
interesting thing is that you can look
at your grid search results and then see
that yeah when you
tweak your threshold parameter here then
you can see that just this one basic
rule
you know it kind of already is able to
achieve
60 ish accuracy and uh you know 80
precision and just by making
this rule-based system there's also this
notion that you're going to understand
your data just a bit better
and it's not just this moment where you
can make a classifier to make like
something that's accurate
what you can also do is make systems
like this you can also make systems that
take pre-existing machine learning tools
and turn those into a rule-based system
as well
there's a bit of an example that i'll
quickly just show you here the most
important thing to take away from this
is that we have an outlier and a
classifier model
and effectively what's happening inside
of this function is we're saying this
np-where clause
a couple of times where if this
predicate holds then we are going to
override
the prediction that we start with so
if nothing happens we just go for the
classification that we had
but if where the probability is not high
enough then we have this fallback
scenario
otherwise we have another fallback
scenario and lo and behold you now have
a system that can do the won't predict
thing
just by using tools that are available
already
so we have these function tools they are
available as a classifier or aggressor
and as well as an outlier detector
but there's one other thing that i think
is going to be a more interesting
direction for this project
because maybe we can not only think of
how do we make
rule-based systems easier but also how
can i make it easier to come up with
rule-based systems in the first place
and that's and the best way to summarize
that actually is just to look at this
chart
um this is like the iris data set this
is just some sort of
chart that you can look at and i think
the reason why
a lot of us resort to machine learning
probably has to do with the fact that
it's kind of hard to automatically you
know
come up with code that can sort of draw
a shape around
a data set if you will it'd be kind of
nice if instead of
you know it'd be nice if we can just put
an if statement down here and we'd have
the shape
but unfortunately code is not the right
way to get there
but one thing that we can do basically
maybe
draw a classifier
to be honest the way that this works um
we've got these point-and-poly
algorithms right
so i can make a drawing of polygons of
interest
and i can say well some of these
polygons have a name attached that
coincidentally is attached to the
name of a class and with these drawn
polygons i can also come up with nice
little rules
like the obvious rule could be well if a
data point uh falls into a polygon
that's an excellent reason to say ah it
probably belongs to a class
another thing that i can do is i can
maybe not just make one of these
drawings i can probably make many
and then i can average between the
polygons that you fall into
thing that i can kind of do is i can say
well if you don't fall in any polygons
you're probably an outlier
but i think the more important thing
that's interesting about this is that
by making models this way not only do
you have maybe a good benchmark for a
model
but you're also doing your exploratory
analysis at the same time
i kind of started getting a little bit
tired of all of these people just
calling
fit predict xy and then calling it a day
if you look at kaggle there's a lot of
that stuff happening it actually kind of
gets scary we shouldn't have that much
faith in our machine learning systems
instead i think it's going to be a lot
nicer to just draw models like this
see it as a benchmark and if this model
already kind of works
that's kind of nice because it also
means that we can maybe make these
drawings for situations where labels are
not available
we can also make these drawings for
those situations and we can also get
domain knowledge in
again if only as a benchmark
a final thing to maybe mention just
because i think it's a really cool
feature uh right let's just also show
that
we can turn that drawing we just made
into a classifier by the way
um so we get the three classes based on
the drawings that we just made
but another thing i think is just kind
of nice to just sort of show you
is that we can also give this chart not
the labels but just
features that we're interested in so
let's say that i'm just kind of
interested in
you know this subset of the data
what these charts also allow you to do
is pass that information onto pandas
so if you're interested in a subset for
research you can also use this tool just
for interactive exploration as well
so that was a brief demo
um you might have a question so one
question could be should i use it
well you're definitely free to it's pip
installable documentation is ready and
there's also lots of tutorials
you might ask yourself should i put in
production i mean it's a month old
maybe not uh open source works when
folks contribute
uh when people contribute to find all
the edge cases and currently the edge
cases are kind of unknown
definitely feel free to collaborate but
um don't put it in production just yet
uh is it perfect nope totally not uh
there's actually an extra risk of data
leakage
definitely watch out for that it's super
dangerous and you also need to think
about what you're doing because you can
also add
bad rules and then you might ask well
vincent why did you make this
well i'm getting tired i'm looking at
these machine learning models
that don't play by the rules and i think
that that's actually a nice analogy of
how we should think about our systems
we need these systems to play by the
rules data professionals need to iterate
on data
and also keep thinking and all this
stuff needs to be easier so this is my
sort of answer to how maybe we should do
this
then you might ask vincent what's your
best feature in this entire package
which is why i asked people like hey
uh shall i end with a poem um
kuhn i will not be doing it in brahms
unfortunately because i think the
minority of the people watching
understand that
um but the best feature of the entire
package is what you can do
is from you learn you can call import
this
and it shows you all the lessons that
i've learned while making this package
in rhyme
why worry about the state of the art
maybe it's time that we all admit
that one size fits all suit is not
bespoke and usually
does not fit computers can flow a lot of
tensors but they never really learn
natural intelligence is still a good
idea and natural stupidity is a valid
concern
there are many ways to solve a problem
but don't let fancy tools get to your
head
why would you choose a predefined
solution if you can create a custom one
instead thanks everyone for listening
if you're interested i will be making
more spacey content keep an eye on
twitter i will definitely have like a
big announcement about that one of these
days
if you're interested in the human
learning thing i've added a free course
on calm code io
it has like a full tutorial so you can
totally go around and check that
if you're interested in nlp though also
just reach out to me i'm doing a bunch
of open source work in nlp space
and there's also a youtube channel where
i explain algorithms if that's of
interest
thanks for listening thank you vincent
actually we have quite some interesting
uh questions so oh wait i want to answer
one question first because the previous
speaker was talking about missing data
right
okay let's let's do that thing first
another way of
dealing with missing data by the way if
you make a model that's like this
drawing
notice that if a data point is missing
on these two columns right
but it's not missing on these two you
can still say oh but it falls in this
polygon so i can still make a prediction
just saying it's another way of thinking
about making uh dealing with missing
data you can also
ignore it anyway questions i guess yes
um a question from uh jorn
why would embeddings not be suitable
wouldn't they be able to encode the
context in which the programming
language tokens appear in
sentences about the beginning of your
talk well if you're going to end up
training your own maybe but certainly
not the predator
certainly not the pre-trained ones right
that's the main thing the pre-trained
ones that are trained on wikipedia
probably will overfit on the general
case and not directly
applicable to what i'm using but that's
the thing like in general the word go is
really reserved to be a verb like
there's no way around that it's really
the most common uh usage for it
even in a sec overflow data set there's
more uses cases for
go being a verb than it for being a
programming language even in this use
case
so training your own embeddings you can
try but it's not easy
okay then on to the
next question from actor
business process management and
integration of machine learning system
inside workflow makes good sense but
does this mean we take data away from a
machine learning model
during training phase or should we train
with full data but only serve the model
for the ones that fall out of the
business domain rules
that's a lot of business terms um so
in this particular case if you're going
to do the drawing approach and even if
you do the function classifier approach
there's not really fitting anymore is it
you're just saying well i as a human
declare these are the rules to follow
and those are the rules you should just
take into consideration
um like um
i forgot about the first part of the
question now sorry
basically it's um
should we train the machine learning
model on the complete data set or only
on the
data that has been filtered by the
business rules oh
um uh i don't have a good answer for
that in general just try it out on your
own data
that's that's i think the best way to to
verify for sure
um again the the risk here is that you
can also come up with rules that make no
sense and are actually bad right so
that's the
new hypothesis you have to concern
yourself with
okay cool then a question from juan
which is quite interesting i think so
the method the iterative method that you
propose would you consider it to be some
kind of active learning
that you apply i mean that's that's one
way of thinking i mean
i'm not super aware of the exact
definition of active learning
um i'm just copying what the spacey
people call it which i
i think enos was the first one to coin
uh iterate on your data instead
and the reason why i sympathize with it
is also that you have to be careful
because
a lot of these labeled data sets can't
really be trusted um
so that's more the concern that i have
i've more the concern that
there might be a labeling issue i
suppose
um then that i'm trying to not label as
much i think active learning as a field
is a little bit more concerned with well
labeling is expensive how can we
minimize the costs
whereas my concern is a little bit more
or do i even trust the data
to begin with yeah i think so basically
what you're
saying is that if you take out of the
box active learning approach probably
it's not really covering it because then
you're still using a model to see
where you're inaccurate while your
business rules actually have a more
human training approach right the the
main reason why i think this approach
works is because the rule-based systems
indeed
work on a very different method than the
machine learning one
with active learning as you just said i
do think it's a valid concern
but if there's bias in your data set in
the first place that active learning is
maybe gonna keep it
and so you're basically using the human
intelligence to find your edge cases
that you're missing if you just look at
your accuracy right
yeah and i think natural intelligence is
still a pretty good idea um
i mean artificial intelligence can work
but human intelligence
sounds good so then
there's another question about um the
snorkel
project uh you're familiar with this
project
a little bit um i've talked to people
who use it so i know people who use it
in fraud situations and
one story i heard is that someone's
actually quite happy with it
i don't know it well enough to
understand the magic that it does under
the hood i believe it basically says
well you got a couple of rules that we
don't fully trust
and then we combine them in a magic way
and then it's better it's just that i
don't understand what the magic way
exactly entails in order for me to give
confidence in it
it really sounds like magic right yeah
so
so there's a little bit of a black box
thing to it also
yeah and again um i wouldn't want to
suggest that rule based systems are the
end all of everything like
it's it's it's more of a tool that you
can use and i think it started getting a
bad reputation even though i keep seeing
it does wonders
um so that's why i figured maybe just
talking about it
um let's see we have actually a lot of
questions
um yeah so i think we're running late
already a little bit so let's move the
questions
to uh to discord and we can continue the
discussion there
meanwhile a little bit of an
announcement we have
one talk that is unfortunately cancelled
so that's the talk about
the second one after the break
from uh three yeah so if some last
minute
schedule changes so just a heads up that
this talk
unfortunately will be cancelled so it's
the one about the reinforcement learning
in greenhouses
so vincent thank you very much for your
talk uh and uh
yeah let's continue the discussion on
this card i will
i will definitely respond to anyone
anytime thanks yes i know thank you
vincent
thanks